bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur public sénat bienvenue
dans dialogue citoyen nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure et demie neuf
citoyens et citoyennes originaires des
quatre coins du pays six sénateurs et
sénatrices tous et toutes venues
échanger sur les inégalités
hommes/femmes confirmé accentuée et
parfois révélés par la crise qu vide il
ya d'abord les violences conjugales le
standard du 39 19 a explosé en 2020 40 %
des femmes sondées par l'ifop affirme
que les actes violents ont commencé à
partir du confinement de mars où un
petit peu après violence mais aussi
pressions diverses discriminations
sexistes inégalités salariales
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours
deux femmes journalistes dans l'univers
sportif mais parfois c'est dans l'espace
public que les femmes sont humiliés ou
mises de côtés autant de sujets sur
lesquels nous allons revenir ce soir
nous donnerons la parole aux victimes et
à celles et ceux qui font bouger les
lignes au quotidien nous verrons comment
les élus de la haute assemblée peuvent
les accompagner peut-être parfois par
des avancées législatives
ce dialogue vous le savez maintenant
vous pouvez le suivre et le commentée
sur les réseaux sociaux hashtag dialogue
citoyen sur twitter il est également
diffusée sur youtube sachez enfin que ce
programme est disponible pour les sourds
et malentendants
avant de vous présenter tous nos invités
quelques images les images d'une
citoyenne qui a fait des violences
faites aux femmes
le combat de sa vie et qui a notamment
décidé de faire de la prévention auprès
des jeunes regarder pendant toute mon
adolescence j'ai rempli des cahiers en
cachette j'avais plein de choses à dire
elle savait pas trop à qui alors je les
écrivais et puis à 15 ans j'ai dû
affronter mon mariage
j'étais assez énervé j'envoie mes
parents j'en voulais à tout les chics
avait accepté avant moi et je m'en
voulais d'avoir accepté alors que je
n'avais pas envie et puis un jour ma
soeur m'a fait découvrir l'album de bams
vivre ou mourir
et cet album je l'écouté en boucle
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
chaque mot chaque phrase résonné en moi
c'était complètement incroyable et puis
sachant son nom m'a fait dire non à tout
ce que je ne voulais pas donc je suis
parti de chez mes parents je me suis
débarrassé de ce mariage avec cette
chanson non alors j'ai écrit un
spectacle autour des violences faites
aux femmes
l'idée c'était de parler de ces
thématiques de façon moins conventionnel
et je me suis mise à jouer ce spectacle
dans les établissements scolaires et sur
un deuxième temps j'ai proposé des
ateliers d'écriture j'en ai fait plus de
120 et pendant ces ateliers c'est passé
d une chose assez extraordinaire c'est
que ça a permis aux personnes aux jeunes
filles aux jeunes garçons de mettre des
mots sur des violences qu'il est qu'elle
subissait et bienvenue diatta ndiaye
c'est vous que l'on découvre sur ces
images vous avez 37 ans vous êtes mariés
vous avez trois enfants vous avez fondé
l'association réseau nantais créer une
application qui vient en aide aux femmes
en détresse c'est un sujet qui vous
touchent de près on l'a compris vous
nous direz si depuis la crise sanitaire
les demandes ont augmenté
martin tekaya bienvenue à vous également
vous avez 69 ans vous habitez à amiens
et vous êtes bénévole dans une
association qui milite pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans tous
les domaines de la société
ça s'appelle femmes solidaires comité de
la somme l'un de vos sujets à vous c'est
la place de la femme dans l'espace
public
il y à des endroits où cette place est
passée la maison et rien d'autre votre
témoignage à suivre anne-laure baratin
bienvenue vous avez 39 ans vous habitez
à aix-les-bains en savoie
vous allez trois enfants de 5 ans 3 ans
et 3 mois en plus
cette grande et jolie famille vous
travaillez vous êtes rédactrice
indépendante pour des entreprises l'un
de vos combats quotidiens vous c'est la
question de la charge mentale pour vous
mais aussi pour les autres et vous nous
expliquerez tout cela avec vous pour
échanger ce soir dominique vais rien
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice union
centriste de l'yonne membre de la
commission des lois
vice présidente de la délégation aux
droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
jérémy bas qui est également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes sénateur communiste
des bouches du rhône membre de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication
diatta ndiaye avant de nous parler de
votre combat associatif convient un
petit peu de voir dans ces images un
mois peut-être de votre histoire
personnelle
elle est forte puisque c'est aussi de là
que tout est parti
vous avez été mariée de force c'est ça
alors effectivement mais c'est vrai que
généralement j'aime
voilà je ne prends pas le temps et je
trouve que je fais assez de choses des
gens contre assez de deux personnes
victimes de différentes formes de
violence que j'ai décidé en tout cas
d'être la porte parole de de toutes les
toutes les victimes que je rencontre
donc j'ai envie de dire que mon histoire
personnelle
effectivement elle elle pousse à
l'engagement est en réalité c'est même
pas mon histoire qui m'a donné envie de
m'engager
c'est de me rendre compte que même face
aux violences il n'y a pas d'égalité
c'est à dire que moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir cette forme de résilience en moi
qui m'a permis de m'en sortir d'avoir
trouvé deux des personnes qui m'ont
accompagné je me dis que dans mon
malheur j'ai eu quand même pas mal de
chance et de savoir que quand on est
victime de violence et peut encore plus
violences con con qu'on subit qu'il n'y
a pas d'égalité avec on peut se
retrouver avec un parcours chaotique où
une histoire de vie totalement
totalement impacté en tout cas pas
réparé ces violences c'est plutôt ça
crie que j'ai trouvé lâche et
insupportable qui m'a poussé à m'engager
parlez-nous peut-être de cette
application appel que vous avez créés
pourquoi l'avoir créé pourquoi le
signalement n'était pas simple en
passant par la police il fallait une
autre
forme de signalement possible pour ces
femmes alors cette application est
l'arrivée en 2015 et en 2015 ça faisait
déjà dix ans que je travaillais sur la
question des violences sexistes et
sexuelles
j'allais dans les établissements
scolaires pour aborder cette thématique
là par le biais d'un spectacle et je me
suis retrouvé avec énormément de
témoignages de jeunes victimes de
violences ou de témoins de violence qui
ne savaient pas que des solutions
existaient qui ne savaient pas que les
associations avaient des dispositifs
poncet pourra comptant les accompagner
et puis ce que je me suis rendu compte
j'ai réalisé sur le terrain que le fait
de dire aux victimes d'appeler la police
ça n'allait pas alors je ne dis pas que
c'est parce que ce n'est pas ce qu'il
faut faire c'est juste que les victimes
ne le font pas pour plein de raisons
différentes
pour plein de raisons diverses elles ne
le font pas parce qu'elles n'ont pas la
possibilité
elles ne le sont pas parce qu'elles
n'ont pas envie et puis après aussi
toutes les situations dans lesquelles
les polices la police ne se déplace pas
donc moi je suis parti de tous ces
constats et je me suis dit il faut
proposer une solution une autre solution
en tout cas quelque chose de
complémentaire à l'appel direct vers les
services de secours
cette application est très simple à l'a4
fonctionnalités une fonctionnalité
d'alert qui permet à l'utilisatrice où
l'utilisateur de définir jusqu'à 3
personnes de confiance qui ressemble qui
recevront cette alerte lorsque l'alerté
est enclenché mais personne de confiance
entendant direct ce qui se passe et on
le suivait gps en temps réel donc elles
savent elles comprennent ce qui m'arrive
elles savent où je me trouve et avec ces
informations il peut organiser les
secours
un soutien à la victime parce que je
vais pouvoir appeler la police en leur
disant il se passe-t-elle chose à tel
endroit
allez-y et ce qui est innovante dans
cette alerte c'est que le tout est de
quotas est automatiquement enregistré
que vous avez remarqué une augmentation
d alerte qu'est-ce que la crise qu'ovide
bresse que la crise qu vide à changer
des choses
donc oui effectivement pendant lé coded
c'est que l'application a pu être
utilisée plus facilement que l'appel
direct vers les secours par exemple
parce que lorsque l' alerte est
enclenchée c'est une alerte qui est
discrète
ça ne se voit pas donc l'alerté est
enclenché les violences continuent et
les parcelles entendre ce qui se passe
on ne suffisait ps en temps réel et donc
elles peuvent appeler les secours à la
place de la de la victime c'était plus
facile d'enclencher des alertes que de
prendre son téléphone d'appeler le 17 et
de dire ce qui se passe et du coup
est-ce que vous donc pendant le
confinement
on a fait honneur donc on l'a fait une
comparaison de ce qui se passait sur
appel
sur les huit semaines avant les huit
semaines de confinement effectivement on
a eu une forte des utilisations
d'application n'a eu plus de 6400 alerte
qui ont été envoyés en dans le
confinement
vous avez des élus avec vous ce soir
pour pour échanger et qui peuvent faire
évoluer la loi dira iata a indiqué qu
est ce que vous aimeriez leur demander
alors moi ce que j'aimerais leur
demander c'est vraiment je crois que
très peu de personnes se rendent compte
de l'urgence qu'il ya à travailler avec
les jeunes publics quand je parle des
jeunes publics
le public avec lequel on travaille a
créé 90 sont les 15 24 ans pourquoi
c'est urgent de travailler avec ce
public tout simplement parce que on
passe notre temps à intervenir en milieu
scolaire on l'a dans les établissements
scolaires on va à eux et sur ces
thématiques là il peut pas attendre que
les victimes viennent pas nous il faut
leur donner la possibilité et créer des
espaces de discussion qui permettent aux
jeunes de raconter ce qui leur arrive
donc on se retrouve avec les témoignages
de jeunes victimes des victimes directes
mais on a aussi les témoignages de ces
jeunes qui raconte ce qui se passe à la
maison et donc on découvre aussi des
situations de violence conjugale et il
ya une réelle urgence parce que je vous
assure c'est catastrophique
alors je dis que c'est catastrophique on
va en sécurité au rang de star line la
phrase oui c'est juste que quand on
intervient auprès des classes on se
retrouve en moyenne avec 3 entre trois
et cinq témoignages de jeunes donc ça
sous-entend que ça concerne énormément
de monde et il ya très peu de choses et
de solutions qui ont été pensés et pour
ces jeunes vite
mais aussi pour ces jeunes qui raconte
ce qui se passe à la maison ça veut dire
qu'il ya une détresse folle et une
attente folle dominique vais rien qu'est
ce qu'on peut apporter à ces situations
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter à ces
jeunes aux énormes 1 3 4 jeunes par
classe on parle de très jeunes 15 24 ans
c'est ce que toutes les associations
disent et c'est pour ça qu'on dit aussi
que dans une classe de terminale puisque
en général un mineur 20% à peu près des
mineurs sont confrontés à une violence
c'était le travail sur les violences
sexuelles mais évidemment si on inclut
les violences intrafamiliales ça touche
beaucoup de jeunes comment faire mieux
les écouter plus les croire on a
toujours ce problème là d'ailleurs que
quel que soit le type de violence que ce
soit vis-à-vis des enfants ou vis-à-vis
des femmes
le problème de il faut les croire et il
faut être formé pour pouvoir entendre
parce que c'est pas aussi simple que ça
et c'est vrai qu'on le demande depuis
longtemps et qu'on a besoin alors la
gendarmerie mme je suis en zone
gendarmerie évolué mais c'est jamais
assez vite
la police doit évoluer aussi sait jamais
a ses forces et je pense que si on peut
déjà poussé plus vers ça et d'aider les
associations ne pas les laisser tomber
parce que on le voit bien ce sont les
associations qui vont effectivement au
contact et il est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'appeler quelqu'un
de confiance que de se dire qu'on va se
rendre à la police surtout si on pense
qu'on sera pas cru ou si on y est déjà
allé et que ça donnait rien et on le
voit tous les féminicides souvent les
femmes avaient déjà donné un signalement
au départ et a été écouté un diaryatou
bah ils n'ont pas eu bien entendu c'est
surtout cela on parce qu'on n'a pas la
formation pour entendre ce qui se passe
pour de vrai et et on a du mal à croire
la victime
muriel salmona en parle très bien la
victime du mal à être cru parce que ben
elle n'a pas la réaction que le policier
qui n'est pas formé
attends dire iata intel vous voulez
ajouter quelque chose je crois oui tout
à fait donc effectivement je pense et je
le répète je pense qu'il faut aller dans
les établissements scolaires il faut
aller en direction du public
elle a posé la question parce que
généralement quand on pose la question
les jeunes répondent est effectivement
pour concernant le fait d'être entendus
ou pas lorsque les plaintes sont
déposées alors déjà par rapport à notre
public
la police déjà il ya déjà de la défiance
parce que quand on est jeune ben c'est à
la mode aussi de d'avoir de la défiance
envers la police et en plus quand on
voit des témoignages même des adultes
qui déposent plainte ou qui dénonce les
violences d'ailleurs en ce moment sur
twitter il ya le hashtag pro ma plainte
avec tous les témoignages de personnes
qui sont allés déposer plainte
effectivement il ya un vrai problème
quand les violences sont dénoncés et je
pense que c'est vraiment super important
surtout en direction des jeunes publics
vraiment si on ne les croit pas ça peut
vraiment avoir un réel impact parce que
ce sont des personnes qui vont se taire
pendant très longtemps les personnes
parlent
il faut qu'elle soit entendue jérémy bé
qu'est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas forcer
les forces de l'ordre entre guillemets à
être fort mais est ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas imposer ces formations salle devient
un vrai sujet alors effectivement moi je
crois qu'il faut à la fois libéré la
parole tout le monde le dit les
associations
j'étais auparavant assistant social
avant d'être sénateur et j'ai dû
accompagner un certain nombre de femmes
de jeunes filles victimes de violences
et est donc on mesure le parcours du
combattant moi je vais prendre l'exemple
que j'ai pu connaître
professionnellement quand vous vous
rendez dans un commissariat qui lie à
une vingtaine de personnes dans le hall
d'accueil que l'agent de police nous
appelle à la banque du commissariat pour
vous dire mais madame vous venez pour
quoi que tout le monde en tant qu il y a
des gens du quartier qui connaissent
d'ailleurs peut être l'agresseur
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est une
double violence en fait qui se rajoute à
la violence déjà subi par la victime
donc effectivement il ya une partie qui
est libération de la parole est ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on en fait c'est par
libérer libérer
comment on la prend en compte et c'est
ça le véritable enjeu moi je le vois en
espagne le gouvernement espagnol il ya
deux ans a mis un milliard d'euros sur
la table à la fois pour protéger les
femmes mais aussi pour investir dans la
prévention dans la formation des
professionnels
que ce soit des forces de l'ordre du
personnel enseignant pour justement
détecter accompagné suivre et protéger
les publics victimes de violences alors
martine tekaya vous la maltraitance des
femmes
ça passe aussi par une place qu'elles
n'ont pas toujours dans l'espace public
en tout cas on qu'on ne leur laisse pas
vous ce que vous voyez au quotidien ce
sont des femmes qui doivent rester à la
maison vous dites même quelque chose de
très fort c'est ce que vous avez dit en
préparant cette émission elles sont
confinées toute l'année qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
elles sont confinées toute l'année ça
veut dire qu'une grande partie ces
femmes ont pour objet la leaf a pour
objet de vous conduire les enfants à
l'école reviennent de l'école font le
ménage je prépare la maison
elles vont ensuite rechercher souvent
les enfants pour le déjeuner les
reconduire à l'école l'après-midi et
elles vont l'après-midi éventuellement
aller dans une association à proximité
de chez elles ou essentiellement en
valeur proposé de faire de la couture du
tricot de la cuisine donc elle reste en
fait
confiné dans le quartier et confinés
dans leurs activités
ça veut dire qu'elles n'ont pas de place
pas d espace pour aller simplement se
promener errer dans les rues comme elle
comme elles le veulent s'il n'y a pas
une tâche précise et en particulier en
lien avec les enfants ou une tâche
ménagère
voilà tout à fait certaines femmes nous
ont dit on a faim on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une marche exploratoire dans un
quartier nord d'amiens qui est un
quartier à 70% de l'eau
sociaux avec un niveau de vie très en
dessous du niveau 10 moyens damien avec
des descend en grande fragilité et ses
fins nous en montrer tous les problèmes
qu'elle pouvait rentrer au quotidien qui
passait par le fait que par exemple
oui quand il faisait beau il n'y avait
pas un endroit où elle pouvait se poser
sur un banc discuter entre elles restées
dehors on s'est promenés par exemple à
un endroit où tout de suite on a été
accosté par une bande de quatre singes
d'hommes qui sont venus nous demander
mais qu'est ce que vous faites là
attention vous faites des photos qu'elle
photo ça voilà une certaine agressivité
hélas ces femmes ils ont envie de l
envie d'autre chose elles ont envie de
ne plus être des mères de famille mais
d'être aussi des femmes
ça vient d'où selon vous un martin
tekaya ce sont des c'est le poids de
codes ancestraux c'est quoi ça vient
d'où ça oui ça c'est un système
patriarcal que l'on subit en france il
ya aussi dans ces quartiers bien sûr
beaucoup de femmes qui sont qui ont des
origines étrangères de différentes
origines
d'ailleurs il ya des femmes du maghreb
et des femmes d'afrique il ya des femmes
qui viennent des pays de l'est mais où
il ya toujours cette culture patriarcale
mal qu'on connaît nous aussi d'ailleurs
beaucoup de femmes en france ont été
élevés dans cette culture et où l'homme
domine et où l'homme décide pour la
femme et l'homme envahi l'espace
extérieur
on le voit par exemple dans ce quartier
il ya un marché très très connus on peut
arriver assez souvent le dimanche matin
on peut considérer bien facilement 70%
d'hommes au marché pour 30% de femmes
donc les hommes continuent à envahir
l'espace public
les faits ne vont pas dans les réunions
ces femmes martina et 110 familles et
comme elles le veulent je crois que
certaines se change quand elles arrivent
dans votre association mais elle n'ose
pas s'habiller comme elles l'auraient
dans la rue voilà c'était pas dans notre
association mais je racontais ça quand
je travaillais en effet il y avait des
jeunes femmes qui arrivait avec une
tenue cassant tout à fait leur forme et
quand elle arrivait dans l'entreprise
elle changeait tenu parce que quand
elles sortent du quartier ya le regard
des hommes et elles ne peuvent pas
sortir habillé comme elle le souhaite
jérémy baky en 2021 des femmes qui ne
peuvent pas sortir dans l'espace public
comme elle le voudrait aussi libres
qu'elles le voudraient en tout cas pas
aussi libre que les hommes par nonce
c'est fou non
c'est insupportable plus que fout c'est
insupportable pour plusieurs raisons
parce que madame tekaya le disait très
justement j'en parlais y compris avec
les collègues de deux femmes solidaires
dans mon département
on est effectivement dans une société
patriarcale il ya un poids de l'héritage
est bien souvent réalité que ce soit les
femmes ou les hommes on se conforme dans
un moule dans une reproduction des
schémas anciens qui nécessite en réalité
pour ça que je reviens sur ce qu'il
disait tout à l'heure je crois qu'il
faut prendre ces questions en compte dès
le plus jeune âge il ya un véritable
travail éducatif
il ya un vrai travail d'égalité femmes
hommes
dès le plus jeune âge en réalité y
compris dès la maternelle parce que est
aujourd'hui et pour ces femmes qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire parce que ok
l'éducation pour les plus jeunes pour
les générations futures c'est très bien
sûr mais aujourd'hui pour celles qui
vivent ça aujourd'hui il ya des
quartiers où elles ne peuvent faire ce
qu'elle m'aime moi je crois qu'il faut
accompagner aider le pouvoir public il
est aussi là pour permettre à ces femmes
de pouvoir faire ce qu'elles veulent en
toute sécurité et ensuite avoir un
travail véritablement en profondeur pour
changer les mentalités je reviens là
dessus parce que c'est extrêmement
important
je le dis d'autant plus que je considère
qu'en réalité l'homme ou une partie des
sommes sont aussi enfermé dans un rôle
de domination et je considère que
l'émancipation des femmes participent
aussi de l'émancipation de tout le monde
et de l'homme une fine et qu'il ce qui
pourrait se libérer de ce rôle de
dominants et je crois que c'est une
bonne chose et c'est pour ça que j'aime
vite je le dis en tant qu'homme aussi
les hommes être attentif à c'est assez
combat là et pâques attentif à
accompagner et à méditer compris dans
des associations qui qui prône l'égalité
parce qu'on
pas se désintéresser de cette question
là il considérait que c'est qu'une
question qui doit intéresser les femmes
martine tekaya oui je rejoins c'est je
rejoins l'idée en effet que c'est très
jeune qu'il faut intervenir dans les
écoles nous nous intervenons dès la
maternelle et les écoles primaires parce
que c'est à cet âge là qu'il faut déjà
orienté les enfants de l'égalité femmes
et hommes
un autre point important ce sont les
budgets des associations sur ce quartier
où nous avons fait les matchs les
marches exploratoires
il ya une multitude d'associations qui
se débrouille qui n'ont rien fait qui ne
venons pas de subventions suffisantes
pour pouvoir former des femmes les
amener à prendre la parole il faut faire
des formations par exemple pour et des
femmes à prendre la parole
on ne les voit jamais dans les réunions
politiques ou très peu ce sont les
hommes qui viennent dans les réunions
politiques
alors on en voit très peu j'ai un peu
faim jérémy baky et dominique vert alors
quelques secondes
très rapidement je crois qu'il ya aussi
un travail de récupération sur l'égalité
salariale qui donne aussi une femme une
place aux femmes dans la société on a vu
une progression jusqu'au début des
années 90 et depuis les années 90 une
sorte de tassement à 25 % de l'écart de
salaire entre les femmes les hommes et 2
c'est aussi comment on revalorise le
rôle des femmes dans l'histoire elles
sont un vide et un dîner risée de
l'histoire du pays alors qu'elles ont un
rôle majeur que ce soit la révolution
française à 36 dans la résistance à la
libération
elles ont participé à l'histoire de
notre pays et elles sont invisibles des
livres d'histoire c'est aussi ça
permettra la femme de revenir dans
l'espace même dominé guérilla pas des
mesures d'urgence à prendre alors c'est
très inégalitaire on voit bien qu'il ya
des quartiers où effectivement la femme
est totalement à signer alors que dans
d'autres endroits c'est plus libre
l'école dès le départ ça c'est évident
je crois que le travail est en train de
se faire et après aider les associations
parce que dans certains quartiers ça
relève du combat est donc là il faut
militer il faut il faudrait utiliser
l'espace et se montrer dans l'espace est
obligé
finalement les hommes à nous y voir une
présence de forces de l'ordre c'est
qu'une présence je pense que ça suppose
le fait que des hommes et des femmes
mais aussi des hommes
enfin seulement des femmes des hommes et
des femmes s'unissent à et combattent et
10 non cet espace n'est pas à vous n'est
pas le vôtre c'est aussi le nôtre et
c'est à nous de nous emparer de l'espace
donc à nous les femmes mais c'est tous
ensemble qu'on doit pouvoir le faire
je ne crois pas que ce soit les forces
de l'ordre qui pourront arriver à quoi
que ce soit vous imaginez bien que c'est
pas forcément très pacificateur dans un
cadre mais les associations avaient
sécurisé les associations et là pour le
coup on peut accompagner des
associations pour effectivement faire
des choses pour pour pouvoir
s'approprier des cafés on peut tout à
fait faire des cafés philo et puis et y
aller il ya je crois que il faut pas
qu'on se laisse faire le vrai problème
en fait c'est que on est éduqué pour
laisser les hommes faire et puis on se
dit bon ma foi et on s'en accommode
eh bien il ya un moment on doit pas s'en
accommoder d'où l'intérêt de leur
démarche exploratoire dont vous avez
parlé martin tekaya and leur baratin
avec vous on aborde un autre type de
souffrance moins lourd peut-être mais
aussi très concernant c'est la question
de la charge mentale que vivent des
millions de femmes dans votre cas je
crois que c'est l'arrivée du premier
enfant qui a changé la donne pourtant
avec votre mari vous vous viviez comme
un couple moderne est ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter peut-être en quelques
secondes ce qui s'est passé moi j'ai
découvert la charge mentale
effectivement avec l'arrivée de notre
premier enfant
j'ai surtout découvert qu'un couple
compense moderne qui partage des tâches
sans avoir jamais vraiment réellement
parler pour qui c'est un non sujet peut
se retrouver en fait dans un
déséquilibre total
lors de l'arrivée d'un enfant et
notamment lors du congé maternité et les
conséquences du congé maternité quand
vous reprenez ensuite votre travail
voilà c'était dire que vous êtes senti
vous aussi assigné à certaines tâches
parce que femme alors que votre mari je
précise ne n'est pas sexiste machiste
non non pas du tout et on y est c'est
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle moi
j'aime pas trop le terme les hommes
modernes mais malheureusement quand vous
êtes seul à la maison avec un bébé vont
passer toute la journée avec lui et que
votre mari rentre le soir du travail
vous prenez des automatismes où vous
retrouvez ces boues qui savait gérer
l'enfant qui fait les démarches pour les
modes de garde qui sont en général
effectivement compliqué et ça amène un
déséquilibre assez important et ce
déséquilibre ou leur santé d'autant plus
quand vous retourner travailler parce
que vous allez prendre le prix de
déposer l'enfant à la crèche le matin
puisque vous avez fait les démarches
dont vous connaissez les genres à la
crèche et après ce n'est pas qu'une
histoire de groupe c'est aussi une
histoire de société où la parentalité
est encore considéré comme quelque chose
qui relève des maires de celles qui ont
porté l'enfant dans ce que vous dites on
a l'impression que pardon dans ce que
vous dites puisque vous parlez beaucoup
de ce congé maternité qui semble à
signer les femmes ça veut dire que vous
êtes pour un congé paternité obligatoire
exactement complètement pour moi c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui ferait la
différence et qui permettrait de réduire
les inégalités etc aurait des
conséquences
ultra positif pour la suite que ce soit
en entreprise ou même en tant
qu'indépendante parce que je précise que
ça va vraiment être un défi pour la
france va y avoir de plus en plus
d'indépendants et notamment de femmes
qui pensent quitter le monde de
l'entreprise pourra avoir plus de
liberté et cette liberté
il faut aussi expliquer aux autres à son
couple à ses prestataires à l'école à la
société que c'est pas du temps forcément
on veut l'utiliser pour plus passé avec
ses enfants mais que c'est un choix on
peut l'utiliser pour soi et pour son
entreprise
voilà un sujet très politique dominique
vais rien ce congé paternité obligatoire
vous êtes pot au pin oui je suis pour
parce que ça rétabli justement cet
équilibre et on voit bien que le
problème se pose dès le départ et dès le
départ on doit pouvoir partager les
tâches et on doit pouvoir être deux à
s'occuper de l'enfant donc je pense que
c'est
on a bien imposé le congé maternité je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
quel cauchemar comment ça peut prendre
forme d'un point de vue législatif
jérémy bas qui est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut parce que beaucoup de
gens ne savent pas comment fonctionnent
les lois les navettes parlementaires les
procédures parlementaires proposent et
faire une proposition de loi sur le
congé paternité obligatoire c'est
possible ou pas c'est envisageable après
est-ce que sa maîtresse deux ans être
est remplacé est ce que celui ci sera
votée ou pas moi je ne connais pas
aujourd'hui à la position de l'ensemble
de l'échiquier politique soient haussées
blau sénat pardon ou à l'assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet là mais
effectivement je partage je pense que il
faut très rapidement notamment sur les
questions de parents parentalité
accompagné aussi à la paternité et ne
pas considérer que les tâches relatives
à la parentalité devrait être quasi
exclusivement conférer à la mer et je
crois que c'est pas toujours par
mauvaise volonté des pères mais il ya
aussi une reproduction de schéma ancien
qui qui s'installe peu à peu et madame a
raté le disait très justement et je
crois qu'il faut que le législateur et
les parlementaires que nous sommes on
puisse parfois accéléré même processus
parce qu'effectivement il ya le temps
long comme on n'influe sur les
mentalités mais comment les législateurs
que nous sommes on est en capacité par
la loi de faire accélérer un processus
et modifier considérablement les
mentalités je crois que c'est les deux
et d'une phrase très rapide
je crois que les grands bouleversements
y compris par rapport à la vie des
familles dans le pays se sont produits
parce qu'il y avait une mobilisation
populaire et je le vois en espagne et
une grande
mobilisation des femmes 2017 2010 qui
aboutit justement ce plan de milliards
d'euros mis sur la table par le
mouvement espagnol et je crois qu'on a
intérêt aussi avoir à la fois une prise
de conscience grande en dépit d'une
mobilisation populaire
couplé à l'activité parlementaire pour
pouvoir faire avancer considère le
danger paternité vous le prendriez vous
écoutez moi ainsi s'il existait s'il
existe est très bas il existe en
l'occurrence est obligatoire juste un
nom il n'est pas obligatoire moi je le
dis j'en informerai le président du
sénat gérard larcher pour lui dire
effectivement que le temps qu'il faut
mais y compris toi parce que ça fait
bien mais parce que le futur père que je
serais peut-être dans quelques mois ou
quelques années aura aussi à coeur de
passer du temps avec son sa nouveau né
pour le coup et son épouse dans les
moments un peu privilégié et donc je
crois que c'est important et ça
participera de mon point de vue aussi à
modifier la perception du rôle de la
femme dans l'entreprise parce qu'on voit
tous les frais en embauche tous les
frais à la promotion interne des
entreprises liées à la maternité sino
mais les pères de famille s'arrête de la
même durée que les mères de famille dans
ces temps là ça changerait tout mais
peut-être que on réduira dans
l'entreprise et les exercices un moment
à l'école aussi effectivement ou les
réunions du soir mekla lieu les
invalides extrascolaires les rendez vous
chez le médecin chez le dentiste gagnent
leur baratin
oui un peu juste pour rebondir ce que
dit monsieur le sénateur c'est que
justement en espagne là depuis 2002 21
il ya seize semaines de congé rémunéré à
100% qu'ils sont accordés au deuxième
par an et ça ça change complètement la
donne change complètement d'accord ce
que vous disiez c'est l'entreprise elle
verra que la parentalité et à 50 50
ça permettra aux fans d'avoir moins ce
stress d'accepter des nouvelles
promotions de se mettre sur le devant
est aussi serein effet je pense qu'on
dit soudan a pas de femmes en politique
mais parce qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes
qui ne sent qu'elles n'ont pas leur
place
et parce qu'elles ont la tête plein de
choses tout ce qui touche à la vie
domestique
c'est la femme et j'espère qu'un jour on
va considérer que tout ce qui touche à
la vie domestique c'est un vrai sujet
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
pouvoir évoquer en
le dès le début sans que ce soit un
sujet tabou sans que ce soit un sujet
embêtant voilà est un tout petit mot
dominique guérin cette charge mentale et
ce qu'il faudrait pas envisager une
reconnaissance de cette charge mentale
d'un point de vue législatif pour les
entreprises pour qu'elles tiennent
compte de cette charge mentale qui
existe un kir elle je crois pas que ça
relève de législatif objectivement je
crois que ça relève de la société et
qu'il faut qu'on en prenne conscience et
qu'il faut qu'on lutte contre l' aussi
mais je crois pas que ça relève du
législatif mais ça permettrait de rebouc
l'est aussi sur ce que disait diarra tu
as tout à l'heure je pense que lors du
confinement
on a revu aussi tout d'un coup on était
tous confinés à la maison et là on a
revu des rôles traditionnels se
reprendre et c'est la femme qui se
prenaient les enfants la cuisine etc
d'où à mon avis quelques querelles qui
ont dû aussi pouvoir être un peu plus
violentes et merci merci à toutes et à
tous de participer à ce premier échange
dans un dialogue citoyen on va
maintenant se pencher sur ce que vivent
les femmes dans le monde du travail
justement les choses évoluent mais pas
encore assez vite les inégalités
salariales sont criantes
chez les cadres par exemple l'apec nous
dit qu'à poste et profil équivalent les
hommes gagnent 7 % de plus que les
femmes même l'europe s'en mêle et
demande aux états membres de mettre des
amendes aux entreprises qui ne
régularise pas les situations sans
compter évidemment certains postes qui
sont encore attribué seulement à des
femmes pourquoi et comment y remédier
c'est le thème de notre deuxième partie
je vous repose d'abord de découvrir de
nouvelles images cette fois elles nous
viennent d'une citoyenne qui a fait
carrière dans un monde à priori plutôt
masculin elle est propriétaire d'un
garage et son quotidien il ressemble à
ça bonjour je m'appelle charlène j'ai 30
ans et je suis gérante d'un garage
automobile
mais écoutez je vais vous faire une
visite de mon garage tant attendu voilà
donc là nous sommes dans le showroom et
l'accueil et on va les voir l'atelier
mécanique ou mes collaborateurs
travaillent
bonjour
bon bah on pouvait voir des temps qui
travaillent et puis yann également donc
on va les voir maintenant l'extérieur
voilà tout ça pour vous dire en fait que
mais je suis fier de mon garage
c'est une moi c'est quelque chose
réalisation en fait parce qu'il ya des
formes concrétisation bas de ma
détermination et de ma patience car pour
l'acquérir
c'était un peu compliqué mais j'ai
réussi dans ce milieu d'hommes
voilà est bienvenu charlène antique
c'est vous qu'on découvre sur ces images
vous avez trente ans vous avez donc
votre garage à ploubalay dans les côtes
d'armor en bretagne depuis septembre
dernier la mécanique c'est un peu une
histoire de famille chez vous mais quand
vous avez voulu vous lancer seuls les
banques ont eu du mal à vous suivre et
vous dites que c'est clairement parce
que vous étiez une femme vous allez nous
détailler tout cela dans un instant
anita puis joe est également avec nous
bien venu vous avez 57 ans vous venez de
bordeaux vous êtes sans emploi
aujourd'hui mais les inégalités
salariales ça vous parle
vous étiez cadre dans une banque et
lorsque vous avez compris que vous
n'étiez ni promus ni augmenter de façon
totalement injuste vous avez à signer
votre employeur il a été condamné mais
vous l'avez payé cher et vous allez nous
raconter tout cela
céline arnaud est également avec nous
bien venu vous avez 42 ans vous êtes
conseillère de caisse à toulon depuis
vingt ans les postes des caissières sont
occupés à une écrasante majorité par des
femmes pas d'inégalité salariale chez
vous mais des discriminations des
évolutions de carrière à géométrie
variable et des difficultés pour les
mères célibataires peu voire pas du tout
prise en compte par l'employeur on va
voir sans détails aussi avec vous avec
vous pour échanger ce soir martine
filleul bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice
socialiste du nord secrétaire du sénat
vice présidente de la délégation aux
droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
andré gattolin est également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes sénateur r&d pays
des hauts-de-seine rdp hisser en marche
au sénat vous êtes vice président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées et
vice président de la commission des
affaires européennes
charlène antique je me tourne vers vous
vous êtes donc propriétaire de ce garage
qu'on vient de découvrir
vous êtes aussi chef d'atelier et vous
n'êtes pas du tout donc dans un bureau
mais d'après ce qu'on a compris ça a été
compliqué c'est peut-être encore
compliqué aujourd'hui d'être prise au
sérieux en tant que femme dans cet
univers expliqué nous un peu oui mais
c'était en fait une grande bataille
ouais permanente fin ça fait dix ans que
je suis dans ce monde là et il a fallu
toujours prouver et prouver prouver
prouver et mais en fait ce faire voilà
j'y suis arrivé mais rien que l'exemple
des banques j'ai fait j'avais 50 %
d'apport ce qui est énorme en fait pour
un achat de fonds de commerce
j'ai qu'une banque sur six qui m'a suivi
là parce que oui mais vous n'êtes pas et
que monsieur ou banon je prends le
garage tout seul voilà il y en a un qui
m'a demandé oui mais faudrait commencer
les stations comme une embardée envie de
chercher le mot associé mais non une
attestation maintenant mais une
attestation en fait de votre ancien
employeur comme quoi vous savez vendre
des voitures est ce que je vends
également des voitures
voilà donc des choses un peu et avez
maintenant vous avez votre propre garage
est ce qu'il ya encore cette forme de
sexisme au quotidien par des clients qui
ne vous prendrait pas au sérieux parce
que vous êtes là chef mais il veut pas
s'adresser à vous il veut s'adresser aux
mécaniciens enfin comment vous vivez
savent encore aujourd'hui ah oui oui
mais toujours ans après voilà c'est ça
devient un jeu maintenant parce que les
gens commencent à me connaître
donc en fait it est au début et et puis
au final ça se passe bien qu'ils sont
contents mais c'est vrai qu'au début ils
demandent mais c'est qui le patron
mais jc mois et forcément à chaque fois
j'ai des petites remarques là dessus
quand j'ai un de mes salariés qui à mes
côtés et la personne va aller
directement vers mon salarié et pas vers
moi parce que moi je suis une secrétaire
dans la tête des gens au point que vous
et avec humour en préparant cette
émission que ça aurait été mieux si vous
aviez une moustache et que vous aimeriez
avoir une moustache
enfin exactement ouais c'est ça j'étais
prête à en acheter une
les farces et attrapes là pour la m
quand quelqu'un me demander mais mais ce
qui est le patron quoi vous vous le dit
avec humour aujourd'hui mais on sent
quand même à la fin de cette vidéo vous
êtes un petit peu ému est ce que c'est
un petit peu plus difficile que ce que
vous voulez nous montrer ce soir
alors ma faim faut se battre tous les
jours en fait oui c'est vrai il faudrait
plus qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire de plus
prouver qu'on est autant capable qui est
un homme voire plus mais dans tous les
jours il faut montrer en fait qu'on a
envie de chialer et pas s'arrêter et
voilà j'ai fait énormément de
concessions
pendant dix ans j'ai travaillé
d'arrache-pied voilà aussi mais c'est
pour moi et je commençais le matin à 7h
chine hissel soir à 20 heures pour
pouvoir prouver en fait que j'étais à ma
place clairement c'est que ça vous
auriez un message à adresser aux femmes
qu'ils n'oseraient pas ou qui n'auraient
pas votre force où vous aimeriez qu'on
qu'on en parle au petite fille coco
comment vous voyez les choses pour que
d'autres femmes ne vivent pas ce que
vous avez vécu et que ce soit tous enfin
plus simple mais déjà peut-être
d'arrêter de me diriger dans les écoles
ben les femmes en fait vers quelque
chose qui est dans la normalité entre
guillemets en ce moment coiffe un bon
moment après ça ça évolue quand même
hein mais ce qu'on voit quand même des
femmes qui sont conductrice de camions
enfin voilà des choses comme ça mais à
l'école quand même on dit voilà
toi tu t'es bonne en littérature battue
va aller dans cette danse et douala ou
en bas tu as vraiment tu vas aller plus
dans cette danse est donc cette voie là
jamais on va dire à quelqu'un
de balai dans un garage en tant que
femme on va on va en parler avec les
élus de la haute assemblée vous
n'hésitez pas charles un antique si vous
avez envie d'intervenir quand vous
entendrez les sénateurs et sénatrices en
discuter mais martine filleul c'est vrai
que ça commence dès le plus jeune âge
on a le sentiment d'orienter les petites
filles vers tel métier les petits
garçons vers tel autre métier
on a aujourd'hui charlène antique qui
adore faire de la mécanique et qui bosse
dans un garage et qui est chef dans un
garage mais qui n'arrive pas à se faire
accepter c'est à la fois émouvants alors
elle le dit avec humour mais c'est
triste aussi
oui moi tout d'abord vous dire que je
suis très contente de faire la
connaissance de charlene vraiment son
exemple son parcours mérite d'être
connue d'être diffusée justement auprès
des jeunes filles qui n'osent pas
toujours qu'ils sont effectivement
orientés vers des métiers plus féminisé
et elle parfois ses filles elles font
des choix un peu par convention par
obligation par pression et justement il
faut casser ses idées reçues et ses
préjugés sur les métiers pour qu'ils
soient plus largement ouvert alors oui
moi je crois que nous avons
collectivement je le dis simplement nous
avons un gros travail à faire sur
l'orientation
il faut que dès le plus jeune âge on
ouvre le panel des possibles pour les
filles et pour les garçons a fait des
années qu'on l'entend mais que ça
n'avance pas ou peu je sais pas ça doit
commencer par les livres scolaires par
exemple je crois que ça doit passer
aussi par les médias parce que il ya un
usager serré au type quand on regarde
dans la publicité ou dans les scieries
télé alors vous voyez aujourd'hui des
femmes avocates des femmes juges
mais justement une femme garagiste une
femme aux brocanteurs etc
ça mériterait ça aurait un sens quand
vous regardez la publicité moi je suis
fascinée
et avant d'être sénateur je suis aller
bloquer des magasins de jouets dans les
centres commerciaux de mon département
où il y avait un parcours aux pour les
jouets pour les filles et un parcours
bleu pour les jouets pour les garçons
c'est à dire que on construit
mentalement
l'idée naturellement chez les garçons
d'un stéréotype féminin mais chez les
filles aussi nos stéréotypes où elle
serait enfermée et je trouve que c'est
terrible un moment où on parle de la
diversité ou le service public dit ah
oui on va mettre plus de femmes aux vins
c'est une question aussi qualitative
sait où est ce qu'on met ses hommes
où est ce qu'on met ces femmes et dans
la représentation populaire excusez moi
mais la fiction ce qu'on diffuse alors
de grande écoute extrêmement important
et j'aimerais voir précisément ben
l'histoire d'une femme garagiste après
les bons que martine filleul les banques
qui seraient frileuse parce que c'était
une une chef de garage fameux oui il y a
encore beaucoup d'obstacles pour la
réussite des femmes très concrètement
mais au bout du bout on voit charlene a
réussi à surmonter tous ces obstacles et
moi j'aurais envie de lui dire qu'il
faut qu'elle aille dans les collèges
dans les lycées pour montrer que ça peut
fonctionner et aussi pour la valoriser
pour la rassurer montrer que c'est une
formidable réussite et fret charles m
l'otan pas seulement oui j'oubliais de
dire aussi qu'il y à des réseaux de
femmes qui s'organisent des femmes chefs
d'entreprise et qui permette du coup
d'avoir aussi un peu de soutien de la
part de ces autres femmes chefs
d'entreprise
et puis elles peuvent aussi
collectivement organiser des opérations
de sensibilisation auprès des jeunes
fils alors les femmes dans le monde du
travail ce sont aussi les inégalités
salariales anita peugeot l'égalité
salariale vous vous êtes battus pour
l'obtenir dans l'entreprise dans
laquelle vous avez travaillé pendant des
années vous ni travailler plus comment
d'abord avez vous su que vous étiez
moins bien payés que vos collègues
masculins comment ça s'est mis en place
dans votre esprit comment avez vous
compris tout cela
bonjour je vais préciser que je
travaillais dans un grand groupe
bancaire français qui communique sur un
modèle coopératif et sur des valeurs de
responsabilité sociétale et d'humanisme
c'est important
voir un petit peu le décalage qu'il ya
entre le discours et la réalité
je m'en suis rendu compte commandes
parce que j'ai consulté les bilans
sociaux de l'entreprise et que j'ai
participé dans le cadre de mes fonctions
syndicales à la commission de l'égalité
sur l'égalité professionnelle entre les
hommes et les femmes
donc le bilan social moi j'ai les
consulter parce que j'étais j'avais des
fonctions syndicales mais c'est quelque
chose que tout salarié peut consulter
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand
vous découvrez ça qu'est ce qui se passe
vous vous vous allez revendiquer des
choses commençaient perçu comme ans
s'est vu que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avant soit déjà j'avais quand même
postulé à 27 reprises pour le impose de
catégorie supérieure sans succès je
m'étais rendu compte que des hommes ont
nouvellement entré dans l'entreprise de
sans expérience sans plus de diplômes
que moi obtenez les postes ensuite je me
suis rendu compte de cette inégalité de
salaires donc je les formaliser jeu
formaliser une demande de
l'ajustement de mon salaire sur celui
des hommes de même catégorie nous
prenons employeur par des courriers et
parle j'ai eu des entretiens qu'elle
ment saluera beaupré six ans et je n'ai
obtenu que des aumônes c'est à dire que
l'homme mon employeur me proposer mille
euros d'augmentation sur mon salaire
annuel le juge puisque j'ai engagé
ensuite une procédure dans le juge m'a
accordée 1200 euros par mois c'est à
dire que l'écart de salaire il était de
1200 euros par mois on était dans
l'entreprise à des accords entre eux en
ce qui me concerne en fonction de
l'évolution je suis resté 22 vendre
l'entreprise entre 16 et 31 % d'écart de
salaire avec un homme qui exerce le même
métier que moi je parlais de ce combat
qui vous avait coûté cher cette bataille
juridique vous diriez qu'elle vous a usé
abîmés physiquement qu'elle vous a
fatigués ce que ça votre santé s'est
dégradée à cause de cela de ce combat
pas tout à fait puisque dès lors que
j'ai assigné
enfin j'ai subi des pressions de plus en
plus forte
et ces pressions sont transformés en
harcèlement
ce qui m'a conduit à un arrêt de travail
lorsque j'ai pu reprendre
l'employeur m'a proposé un autre emploi
et en fait ça s'est avéré être un
placard j'ai il m'a confié une mission
initialement pour deux ans qui a duré
deux ans et demi je n'avais quasiment
aucune activité et le peu d'activité que
j'avais à effectuer aux éperviers
un élève du collège vous vouliez à gaz
et lyne hallé entre salariés vous avez
été un peu accompagnés par des collègues
femmes ou hommes d'ailleurs dans ce dans
ce combat alors j'ai eu des soutiens
mais caché parce qu'en fait ce qui se
passe dans l'entreprise c'est que les
collègues ont peur ils savent en
quelqu'un des inégalités et femmes le
savent mais on n'en parle pas et en fait
les collèges ont peur de des effets ce
que je dis
de capillarité on va dire c'est à dire
que si jamais je montre un soutien trop
trop trop visible j'ai peur que
finalement ce soit moi qui sont embêtés
donc je ne veux pas je ne veux pas le
montrer est ce que je voulais dire
également c'est que voyez vous pour vous
montrer le problème c'est que mes
collègues et moi j'avais bien travaillé
le sujet puisque de l'égalité
professionnelle je connais c'est le
sujet j'avais des collègues qui postuler
un emploi de catégorie supérieure donc
ont échangé sur la préparation leur
entretien je leur montrais avec les
chiffres le bilan social qui est quelque
chose de kate indiscutable seven hills
est validée par un expert-comptable
commissaire aujourd'hui voilà côte où tu
te situes par rapport aux hommes de même
catégorie voilà ce que tu peux demander
et elle me disais non je vais pas
demander parce que si j'ai le pouce
c'est déjà bien
je veux surtout pas leurs noms mais je
me suis dit benjamin andré gattolin il
faut arrêter d'être indulgent avec les
entreprises lan on voit bien que les
écarts de salaires continuent on vole on
fait pression sur des femmes quand elles
se battent pour avoir le même salaire là
aussi il ya un sujet il ya un sujet
d'autant que le principe de l'égalité
salariale entre les hommes et des femmes
date est entré dans la loi en 1972 alors
on contrôle il ya il ya quand même une
innovation depuis 1978 comme une part en
il ya la création de l'index de
l'égalité professionnelle
ça commence à porter ses fruits puisque
on voit des évolutions et surtout à la
troisième année on entre dans des
logiques on peut sanctionner les
entreprises a pour le moment il ya
beaucoup ressembler ses index parce
qu'on entend beaucoup d'entreprises qui
maintenant des chiffres super mais la
réalité est là là là c'est un index
généralisée qui est basée sur des normes
d'ailleurs internationale parce que la
notion d'index d'égalité professionnelle
il n'est pas propre à la france il est
usitée dans les pays scandinaves et les
gîtes et au canada une venant des
entreprises danone annoncé des données
très statistiques c'est à dire que ça
fait maintenant l'objet de contrôles
l'an passé où depuis le début de l'indec
je crois qu'il ya eu
de 12000 contrôles qui ont été faites
300 sanctions exercer c'est un début
mais j'irai comme moi on sait où sont
les choses et là l'idée maintenant c'est
de rendre publiques ces éléments c'est
pas toutes les entreprises remplissent
des statistiques
il s'agit de nommer et de dénoncer et
d'entrée derrière dans des procédures de
sanctions qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 1 %
de la masse salariale au gîte à pujaut
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi le name
and shame vous avez pensé à dénoncer
votre entreprise à en donner le nom est
à dire voilà c'est une entreprise qui ne
qui n'appliquent pas la loi et qui fait
du harcèlement dénoncé le team lui
l'entreprise
elle a été tellement violente avec moi
quand je suis allé au tribunal
moi en fait je suis allé le tribunal
pourquoi parce que moi c'est pas
acceptable que je gagne 30 % de moins
qu'un homme parce que je suis une femme
dont parce que les hommes
j'y suis allé également parce que
j'aimais exercer mon métier j'ai même en
8es le conflit donc je suis allé au
tribunal mais je le dénonce et s'il
voulait comme employeur a été très très
violent dès lors que j'ai assigné
je ne venais pas français a levé
lanthier par contre j'ai tenu bon malgré
des menaces et très très violente
vraiment violente 1 j'ai eu un appel où
on me disait ils veulent pas pauvre mais
martin vial
c'est la technique du name and shame
vous seriez pour par exemple
tout d'abord dire que c'est vraiment
révoltant qui puisse encore se passer
des choses comme celles là en 2021 avec
un tel harcèlement
c'est révoltant vraiment je vous jure
on a une remontée de témoignages très
très très nombreux sur cette question et
malheureusement pour rejoindre le
sénateur gattolin même s'il y a un
progrès et qu'il existe bien cet index
en même temps il lâché l'objet 1 par
terra nova d'une tribune qui montre que
cet index n'est pas suffisant doit pas
seulement des critères et qu'il faut
absolument qu'il y ait encore plus de
contrôler notre la personne qui témoigne
notre témoin le prouvent bien il y a
encore beaucoup beaucoup de travail à
faire pour s'améliorer alors name and
shame pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais je
serai dire que c'est un mode violent et
qu'il faut vraiment beaucoup de mental
pour le faire moi je suis toujours
plutôt favorable à ce qu'il y ait un
engagement aux côtés des syndicats de la
personne concernée et des salariés les
des médiations où les corps
intermédiaires et bien 11 cette mission
il faut la faire jouer à plein pour
aider les salariés il faut que les
syndicats soient forts soient
représentatifs et qu'il y ait un maximum
de femmes aussi qui s'engage non mais
c'est la responsabilité pas des
personnes concernées des pouvoirs
publics de dénoncer là l'idée c'est
d'aller vers une obligation de
publication et compris de manière
visible sur les sites des entreprises
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
il ya des faiblesses parce que on
s'attache beaucoup plafond de verre mais
on voit pas
le plafond scotché c'est à dire que dans
ces indicateurs d'index on ne voit pas
la part de très bas salaires qui sont
attribués aux femmes
le salaire anita pujo d'un tout petit
mot peut-être vous vous êtes rendu
compte aussi que ça avait un impact sur
le patrimoine c'est à dire que vous
n'avez pas pu acheter ce que vous auriez
voulu acheter puisque votre salaire
était de 1200 euros inférieur à ce que
vous auriez dû avoir sur wii un écart de
salaire en faire ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que là où un homme va se
loger dans 80 mètres carrés une femme
elle va se loger dans 50 mètres carrés
l'agronome va pouvoir faire des
investissements pour augmenter ses
revenus
une femme pourra pas donc on sait que
l'argent appelle l'argent et l'argent
appelle le pouvoir donc on voit déjà
quarante ans assystem un homme une femme
va pouvoir payer les mêmes études à
sciences économiques en cas de précarité
en cas d'accident de la vie maladie
chômage on sait que les revenus baissent
de façon importante tant qu'une femme
qui quesnoy elle peut tomber dans la
précarité et enfin à la retraite une
femme qui a été discriminée tout au long
de sa carrière elle ne veut pas voir la
même retraite
donc on voit que ça des incidences tout
au long de la vie des femmes tant sur le
plan professionnel que sur le plan privé
donc là c'est la double dessein que joël
la triple peine c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que si je peux continuer oui oui
elle est ici je je je pense qu'il
faudrait l'index égalité c'est très bien
c'est terrain il faudrait donner du
pouvoir davantage de pouvoirs à
l'inspection du travail
une que les femmes sont puisse les
saisir sans aller au tribunal c'est trop
violent d'aller au tribunal c'est trop
violent c'est trop risqué c'est surtout
quand on est en poste moi j'en ai perdu
mon poste et j'en ai perdu ma santé est
également créé un une juridiction dédiée
aux droits des femmes ça serait plus
ambitieux et comme ça ça couvrirait
l'ensemble de la problématique qui
touche les femmes et la place de la
femme dans la société parce que c'est
faut se contenter au droit du travail
j'aime tourner vers vous maintenant
céline arnaud vous après après 12 ans
derrière la caisse
vous gérez aujourd'hui les hôtes et
hôtesses de caisse un métier difficile
un métier assez peu payé peu reconnue
est occupé à 95% par des femmes
pourquoi d'ailleurs pourquoi autant de
femmes à ces postes c'est un métier qui
n'est pas qui ne plaît pas aux hommes
c'est pas assez bien pour eux non je
crois que c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure j'entendais je sais plus qui
c'est qui me disait c'est un stéréotype
c'est une caissière c'est pas un
caissier donc aujourd'hui personne fait
mais pas grand monde qui ont envie
d'être caissière donc assistante de
caisse plus sérieux que vestiaires mais
encore moins 5 et sied donc aujourd'hui
c'est plus des étudiants qui arrivent
donc nous par exemple sur notre ligne de
casson années 90 ses employés il ya dix
ans dans les dix hommes il y en a sept
cdc des contrats et clients et 3 donc il
ya travailleurs handicapés donc il est
là parce que pas être dans les rayons et
après ces deux autres c'est par choix et
comment vous vous expliquer tout cela
comment vous expliquez que ce soit
d'abord les femmes qui se tournent vers
ce verset métier c'est un métier genre
et comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est une
assignation c'est pour les femmes et pas
pour les autres
je sais pas après c'est un métier déjà
où on peut faire à se tendre de caisse
ou peut rentrer dans la grande
distribution 110 corps donc déjà il ya
tout c'est la démarche on n'a pas de
diplôme ont tantôt rendant la grande
distrib après il ya les étudiants les
étudiants qui commencent leurs études
ils ont vraiment besoin d'argent
finalement il reste donc c'est des
étudiants de ronda souvent des
assistantes de questions un pack plus
croire qu'ils ont même pour des études
quand même hein et ce sont des temps
partiels pour la plupart
les atouts des caissières a s'est
imposée de façon romancée du 30 heures
et s'il est si aujourd'hui de pardon
alesi non et si vous voulez faire du
temps plein c'est forcément un autre
poste au sein de du supermarché et un
poste qui est pas forcément accessibles
aux femmes tellache faut porter des
palettes c'est ça alors voilà mais ça
sert et 101e ils nous ont proposé le
temps plein il ya quelques années et
pourquoi dira peut-être moi ce que dix
ans 1 et par contre c'est la polyvalence
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on se
retrouvait à mettre en rayon pour faire
notre plein temps sauf que on est bien
d'accord que tout le monde n'a pas les
capacités physiques aller en riant
en préparant cette émission disaient
qu'ils avaient pas d'inégalité salariale
en revanche vous parliez quand même de
discrimination notamment au retour de
congé maternité en grossesse
expliquez-nous un peu tout ça enfin
l'exemple j'ai été aux leurs donc ça
c'est les jets passe y en a encore mais
on en rollers on va donner les prix
quand ça bloque en caisse c'est ma
première grossesse je me suis arrêté six
mois pour on avait le droit au congé
parental en six mois quand survenue
montchamp n'a eu un changement de chef
de caisse et il m'a mis en caisse alors
que ça faisait des années que j'étais
roller et au moment du du confinement
quand on l'a on a vu qu'il y avait des
gens qui étaient quand même un peu
agressif dans les supermarchés qui était
particulièrement agressif d'ailleurs à
la caisse est ce que vous avez senti
qu'il était aussi agressif parce que
vous étiez des femmes bien sûr oui non
ça c'est facile et d'ailleurs ils le
sont toujours
si ils sont toujours là il ya une colère
énorme d'affaires de la population et
donc toutes leurs colères elle est
remise en pin en fin de parcours donc
sur la ligne de caisse et on a
énormément de gens qui déverse toute
leur colère sur les assistants de caisse
et c'est tous les jours et c'est
répétitif mais moi je trouve ce
témoignage particulièrement
je dirais démonstrative de la situation
parce que quand on regarde les premières
analyses qu'on fait de trois ans de ce
fameux index un des principaux problèmes
en france qui se pose c'est ce tulle
celui du retour de maternité où ça se
passe globalement très mal et dans une
majorité importante d'entreprise puis le
deuxième élément bon c'est toujours le
fameux plafond de verre c'est à dire la
parité dans les dix meilleurs salaires
de l'entreprise avec le troisième
élément qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
mais qui malheureusement n'est pas dans
cet index il faudrait rajouter c'est la
proportion de très faibles saleh de
femmes dans les très faibles salaires
quand on a déjà ces trois éléments
on voit bien le problème structurel
qu'on a en france
et le temps partiel et la flexibilité
c'est ce qui conduit parce qu'on sait
que souvent une mère de famille a aussi
envie d'avoir du temps ou du besoin de
temps simplement par rapport à ses
enfants et la dimension
je dirais genre plus par emmené aux
familles monoparentales aux parents
célibataires c'est la double peine et ça
c'est extrêmement compliqué à faire
changer parce qu'on se rend compte qu'il
ya une série de variables qui se
cumulent et que l'on peut dire l'égalité
salariale c'est très bien mais l'égalité
salariale sans la prise en compte par
exemple familles monoparentales ou
familles non monoparentales et bien
s'accroît alors on aura l'impression qui
a pas de différence à statut identique
est en train de servir en réalité y en a
une à travers d'autres vous valiez
dossier du retour de congé maternité
la loi oblige depuis 2006 une
augmentation légale au retour du congé
maternité mais elle n'est pas respectée
dans 13% des cas sont des chiffres qu'on
a eues il n'y a pas très longtemps
martine filleul
il faut aller plus les voir ces
entreprises se faire plus pression oui
c'est vrai que le moment de la maternité
est souvent un moment difficile pour le
retour dans l'entreprise à la fois il y
à des déclassements des changements de
poste il y à d'autres collègues qui ont
pu prendre des responsabilités alors
qu'on ne pense pas à la femme qui est
restée en congé de maternité et donc bah
oui il faut toujours de la même manière
interpellé les syndicats intervenir pour
que l'égalité hommes femmes dans
l'entreprise soit respectée ceci étant
bon moi je pense que le moment de la
crise qu vide a montré que à la fois les
caissières les femmes de ménage les
auxiliaires de vie toutes celles qui
sont moins en moins bien payés
finalement est moins bien traité dans la
société était absolument indispensable
il nous reste quelques secondes céline
arnaud je vous ai vu réagir vous aviez
peut-être quelque chose à ajouter
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense que
les entreprises ou en tout cas la grande
distribution
y'a plus d'affectation donc aujourd'hui
on est presque polyvalent en non pas en
congé maternité
on va on revient on n'avait pas de poste
oui c'est facile dit détourne toutes les
lois ayant et en parlant effectivement
de on a été indispensable aujourd'hui
nous qu'on aimerait vous demander ce
qu'on a là voilà j'ai la chance de
parler pour pour les employés la grande
distrib une augmentation de salaire oui
on voit se vivre et de plus survivre
absolue ce n'est pas la réalité puisque
aujourd'hui on a été augmenté de 42
centimes brut par jour travaillé
oui donc si c'était ça le remerciement
des grandes distribuer de la grande
distribution
voilà oui je partage complètement le
point de vue pour dire que même d'autres
catégories ont eu des primes non ce ne
sont pas des primes qu'il faut il faut
des revalorisations de
salaire qu'ils soient des vrais
revalorisation de salaire pérenne
mais pour cela il faut j'allais dire
fait remonter les revendications faire
connaître l'exigence d'améliorer vos
conditions de travail aussi sur le temps
partiel
il faut que le les heures de travail par
ci deux temps partiel soit mieux
rémunéré revaloriser et on va s'arrêter
là pour cette deuxième partie mais merci
infiniment merci céline arnaud entendu
votre votre émotion et merci de vous
être livrés sur notre plateau merci à
tous tant d'ailleurs d'avoir participé
et merci andré gattolin plaça à notre
troisième partie on va maintenant donner
la parole à des citoyennes et des
citoyens qui ont fait de ces inégalités
hommes femmes
un combat quotidien et qui ont parfois
trouvé les moyens d'y remédier alors
soit en travaillant sur les mentalités
et en poussant les femmes à se lancer
malgré leurs inhibitions soit en faisant
de la pédagogie de la formation soit
cette fois c'est clair en s'imposant en
imposant des quotas inégalités hommes
femmes
ils et elles bousculent les codes c'est
le thème de notre dernière partie on
accueille nos prochains invités dans un
instant d'abord de nouvelles images nous
viennent d'un homme qui a fait le choix
de rester à la maison de s'occuper de
son enfant et dont l'épousé trouve son
épanouissement professionnel regarder je
m'appelle nicolas rieffel j'ai 41 ans je
vis dans un tout petit village qui
s'appelle mittelbergheim c'est en alsace
si on vit au milieu des vignes cette
pandémie a radicalement changé ma façon
de travailler la même bouleversé avant
je veux voyager énormément j'étais peu à
la maison et mes activités se situent
principalement dans l'événementiel et
dans la gastronomie depuis maintenant un
an je profite pleinement de ma nouvelle
vie de père au foyer et je suis un homme
extrêmement heureux
quoi encore moi comment tu fais voir la
faire à manger
oui
doucement doucement doucement
je citerai un chef d'entreprise qui
disait tout ce que je perds en euros
dans mes business je le gagne 1000 fois
auprès de mes enfants dans cette
pandémie
aujourd'hui je ne changerais pour rien
au monde ma nouvelle façon de vivre
j'adapte aujourd'hui toutes mes
activités à celle ci et je suis prêt en
tout cas à garder autant que faire se
peut cette nouvelle vie de père au foyer
est bienvenu nicolas rifaie bienvenue à
vous bien d'un dialogue citoyen c'est
vous qu'on découvre dans les images vous
êtes chef de restaurant éphémère mais le
confinement du printemps dernier a été
comme un révélateur de votre fibre
paternelle vous avez décidé on vient de
le voir de vous concentrer sur vos
tâches à la maison et de mettre votre
carrière au second plan et ça vous rend
très heureux on vient de le voir et vous
nous nous en reparlerai dans un instant
chloé hermary est également avec nous ce
soir bienvenue vous avez 26 ans vous
êtes chef d'entreprise vous avez monté
votre école d'informatique qui forment
des développeurs et j'allais dire
surtout des développeuse puisque vous
avez 70 % d'élèves femmes
ça c'est votre bataille après avoir
constaté à quel point tout avait été
conçu par et pour des hommes et vous
allez nous détailler sous sa gueule
berthevas c'est également avec nous bien
venu vous avait 43 ans
vous êtes maire de saintes abraham une
commune une commune d'environ 550
habitants dans le morbihan
vous dites vous même que vous n'êtes pas
une militante féministe qui manifestent
dans la rue en revanche vous oeuvrez
pour la parité en politique
au quotidien vous ne laissait rien
passer quitte d'ailleurs à vous faire
une réputation pas très sympathique et
vous nous expliquerez pourquoi avec vous
pour échanger ce soir alexandre à bord
qui au fond teint bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice à l'ère des alpes-maritimes
membres de la délégation aux droits des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les femmes membres
également de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
thomas dessus bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes sénateur écologiste du rhône
vice-président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises membres de
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication
nicolas rieffel on peut dire vous êtes
homme au foyer aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans votre
parcours j'ai cru comprendre en
préparant cette émission que c'était
quand même le le confinement qui avait
été
un électrochoc tout à fait un
confinement vers les activités jeux
chefs d'entreprise à mes activités sont
principalement dans l'événementiel et
dans la gastroplastie donc forcément
deux secteurs qui ont été touchés de
plein fouet par cette endémie et du jour
au lendemain on se retrouve en petits
qu'eux à la maison donc c'est super les
troubles et moi et puis par la suite les
activités qu'ils reprennent pas mon
épouse qui fait un changement radical de
nos parcours professionnels outils avec
un nouvel investissement dans ces
opportunités et le choix de dire binger
aurait finalement à la maison pour
m'occuper d'autres car qui aurait dû
normalement se retrouver en cash puisque
tous les deux on était en activité au
final j'ai adapté mes activités
aujourd'hui à ma nouvelle vie père au
foyer et qu'est ce que vous avez réalisé
en changeant votre activité de vous
rendez compte que de ce que ça veut dire
élever un enfant vous rendez compte de
ce que vivent un certain nombre de
femmes qui restent à la maison pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants qu'est ce que
ça a réveillé aussi une fibre féministe
chez vous qu'est ce que ça a changé
alors vous venez de bord fait quasiment
tout je pense que la fibre féministe
gelé depuis très longtemps parce que
j'ai été élevé par une maman et et par
ma grand-mère au dessus de ce que mon
papa travaille énormément
donc j'ai eu cette chance-là d'avoir
découvert aussi ce que c'était être une
mère au foyer et quand j'étais plus
jeune je voulais faire de métier le
premier était curé quand j'avais 9 ans
et à 10 ans je vais être papa avec si
l'enfant alors déjà avec un c est déjà
pas mal mais mais mais après par la
suite qui qui a véritablement changé
pour moi dans la prise de conscience
aussi ce que c'était un enfant et de
l'éduquer auque au quotidien
quand on travaille on le dépose le matin
et on leur cherche le spa on n'a pas
vraiment conscience de tout ce qui peut
se passer dans la journée deux sont
encore hormis le week end mais qui est
plus sûr du jour prix à la détente et
j'ai vraiment pu me rendre compte et
surtout ces deux dernières semaines
puisque oscar grandi à bientôt deux ans
de la charge mentale que c'est aussi de
ne pouvoir soutenir son enfant de
l'éduquer en plus d'obliger les sociétés
à côté et mon association donc
effectivement c'est un travail à un
autre travail quelque part tu es le plus
beau métier du monde comme disait ma
maman et
et je suis totalement convaincu à tel
point que j'ai modifié
j'ai modifié ma façon pensée
professionnels ti pour profiter en tout
cas pleinement d'oscar jusqu'au moment
où il va aller à l'école c'est un choix
qu'on a fait ensemble avec mon épouse
est une réflexion qu'on a eu pas très
longue
parce que je suis totalement épanoui et
heureux ici quoi le plus dur alors au
quotidien georges et les fouilles n'ont
après le plus dur au quotidien c'est que
un enfant à son âge à l'âge aux quarts
commencent à avoir son caractère aussi
affirmé on est tous les de lever entre
6h et 6h15 le matin donc on commet ses
activités à la fête
37 à 45 il a fini son petit déjeuner
donc on commence une véritable journée
ensemble
donc il faut l'occuper c'est un enfant
qui est afin fiable de la ville il adore
vivre et jouer donc on fait énormément
de choses entendues par le matin on va
se balader ont fait beaucoup d'activités
ensemble me keita fief de 1h 1h30
l'après midi et on continue les
activités ont fait des balades eu la
chance de vivre dans un merveilleux
village avec des villes
donc on s'occupe tout le temps donc de
cl du matin dès 9h30
on vit une journée vraiment plein nico
nicolas rieffel je vous propose
d'écouter maintenant la réaction de nos
élus en plateau sur ce genre de modèle
d'un convoi finalement assez rarement
trop rarement d'après vous en tout cas
peut-être trop rarement aujourd'hui
c'est le sujet de votre émission cela
signifie que c'est pas encore comme un
mois pour moi un homme qui élève son
enfant c'est tout à fait normal ils sont
peut-être trop peu parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'auto censure je crois pas que
ce soit je pense que tout le monde peut
réussir à trouver un aménagement ça doit
parvenir forcément aux mamans de devoir
se sacrifier dans le travail voilà tout
ça c'est un travail des stéréotypes en
fait à déconstruire pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui partager pleinement
l'éducation de son enfant je passais une
fibre maternelle paternel féministe on
disait à l'instant je pense que
n'importe quel parent est capable
d'éduquer
il faut juste
ne pas s'autocensurer et vivre
pleinement son propre projet le projet
de ce papa c'était de passer un moment à
un mot des moments forts avec son enfant
dès le début il faudrait que tout le
monde voilà à quoi tous les papas qui
souhaitent faire cette même démarche
il ay ay et ne se sentent pas coupables
ou regarder travers par la société c'est
ça qui pose le problème aujourd'hui et
le regard qu'on va porter comme pour le
congé paternité pas justement et ça
comment on change est ce que la loi peut
y aider est-ce que vous en tant que vous
pouvez aussi accompagner ce genre de
changement oui évidemment mais là ce qui
est intéressant c'est la période du coc
vide qui a provoqué ce changement se
déplie qu mais en fait les études qui
sont sortis après le premier confinement
elles ont montré que les femmes
notamment les femmes qui est en
télétravail assumer une double charge
encore plus aggravé que d'habitude c'est
à dire que la la c'est un bel exemple et
ça a permis de montrer que un père
pouvait devenir homo foyer ou s'occuper
pleinement de son enfant mais la réalité
c'est que pendant le premier confinement
ça aggrave et notamment la répartition
des tâches à domicile a aggravé la
difficulté pour les femmes de conjuguer
l'arc leur carrière et leur maternité
donc effectivement il faut pouvoir
encadrer beaucoup de choses et notamment
ses sept ans de télétravail il faut pas
que ça soit des temps aussi où ils
gardent les enfants etc
donc il ya effectivement de
l'encadrement à améliorer mais là c'est
une belle histoire mais la réalité est
un peu différente
après le courrier confirmant les rues
que c'est c'est vrai que dans le cas de
nicolas rieffel ça a été le confinement
qui a été le déclic vous l'avait bien
dit mais est ce que le déclic ça peut
pas être un congé paternité obligatoire
par exemple ben oui on non
le sénat a examiné cette proposition il
ya quelques temps dont je suis favorable
au congé paternité et même j'irai
beaucoup géré au delà je comprends même
pas qu'il ya encore des différences
pourquoi hein maman une maman devrait
passer ces quatre mois de congé est pas
le papa donc je pense qu'il faut encore
aller plus loin et bien sûr le rendre
obligatoire pourquoi c'est important de
rendre obligatoire parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup d'hommes qui dans
l'entreprise n'ose pas prendre ces
journées là en fait en imposant aux
pères de famille ce congé dont kevin
maintenant obligés à partir du 1er
juillet me semble devoir prendre
obligatoirement voilà il va quel papa
aujourd'hui peut ne pas avoir envie de
passer les premiers jours de la vie de
son enfant ensemble ça n'existe pas
maintenant je comprends les pressions
dans les entreprises
oh tiens tu prend 7 jours tu étais là
maintenant ça va être imposé donc non
plus le choix et je peux vous dire que
je pense que ça va être une libération
de tous ces hommes qui ont une fois de
plus s'auto censurer par pression des
collègues de travail des débats là les
titres réflexion dans les plis et bien
sûr 2 à 2 qui ne sont rien d'aného
déconstruire me collard il fait tout ce
qui vous retenez vous pour franchir ce
pas tout seul parce qu'on l'a vu c'est
le confinement qui a été un déclic mais
qu'est-ce qui vous reconnais c'est vrai
il y avait une forme de pression sociale
non j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un papa
qui partagent énormément et nous mais
clairement c'est le travail et un facial
de boulot en 2009
voilà pour donc sur un mois je dormais
fille nuit à la maison donc c'était
vraiment le travail est vraiment envie
de travailler d'être en mouvement de
voyager et c'est vrai que je fais paraît
brutale vraiment replanter les villes
d'eau au milieu du village en biaisant
ballon le l'essentiel c'est papa et avec
cette phrase que je retiendrai dans papa
chef d'entreprise qui a dit tout ce que
je perds en business ou en euro en
données d'entreprise je le gagne 1000
fois plus en reste avec les enfants il
est clairement ça aujourd'hui ça remet
vraiment les les choses en place et
peut-être qu'on est dans une société qui
va trop vite peut-être les choses vont
trop vite évolué et on a oublié
l'essentiel que quand on a décidé de
faire un enfant puisque c'est une
décision en général
et c'est qu'il faut les assumer les
enfants sont pas juste fait pour aller à
gauche et alors on va continuer de
balayer les solutions les pistes
d'avenir avec vous chloé remarie pour
faire avancer les choses en terme
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
vous avez créé votre propre école qui
délivre un enseignement qui se seraient
libérés et là je cite vos mots de
certains billets genre et c'est ça oui
absolument
donc on est une école qui forme à
l'informatique l'informatique
aujourd'hui il ya seulement 10 % de
femmes il peut s'interroger pourquoi
elle que 10% de femmes c'est au même
titre un peu pourquoi il y actuellement
si peu d'hommes qui sont employés c'est
pour en fait tous ces chemins de
décisions qui sont on va dire tracé par
la société c'est que en fait conduit on
pousse plus les femmes à aller vers des
métiers du service que des métiers
scientifiques
quand je dis pousser c'est un contexte
social c'est l'éducation c'est le fruit
n'est malheureusement d'être extrêmement
de levier extrêmement insidieux dans
l'éducation et nous en fait on s'attaque
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est un
problème qui est pas de même dans
l'informatique c'est que les outils
numériques on utilise qui sont les
applications qui sont les réseaux
sociaux etc sont aujourd'hui créées en
très grande majorité par des hommes de 4
90% par des hommes ce qui se passe en
fait c'est que l'on introduit des
billets dans les algorithmes dans la
conception de ces outils qui sont des
bières en fait du coup de coûts de
conception de rue donne un exemple sur
une application de running pour faire
son jogging
on a des personnes qui ont pensé en fait
quand on croise un autre joker on a la
possibilité de voir le parcours que ce
joggeur a fait donc en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que quand en joggeur croise
une joggeuse
il voit en fait l'intégralité de où elle
est partie et douai ce qu'est la rentrée
donc du coup en fait où elle habite
ça par exemple c'est un outil de
conception de périr dablement beaucoup
d'hommes qui sont pas en fait projeter
dans le fait que quand on est une femme
qu'on fait son jogging à 22h on n'a pas
du tout envie de savoir
on n'a pas envie que la personne qu'on
croit sache où on va courir et où est-ce
qu'on rentre chez soi donc l'idée en
fait date ex cool c'était c'est de
proposer une école puisque l'éducation
est toujours à le berceau de toutes les
inégalités mais ici dans le cadre
professionnel c'est une voie d'accès à
les métiers de proposer une école qui
arrive à déconstruire les liait
d'orientation pour les femmes de les
former dans un environnement dans
lesquelles elle se sent bien
je pense qu'on parlait peut-être
justement de culture avec nicolas donc
l'idée c'est de créer un environnement
dans lequel elles se sentent elles se
sentent à l'aise légitime
et puis ensuite d'autres avec des
entreprises qui sont engagés le signe en
ce sens chloé remarie vous avez fait une
grande école de commerce
est ce que vous avez subi le sexisme des
inégalités hommes femmes est ce qu'on ne
vous a pas toujours prise au sérieux là
aujourd'hui vous êtes chef d'entreprise
est ce que vous sentez qu'on ne vous
prend pas au sérieux parce que vous êtes
une femme est ce que vous le vivez
encore aujourd'hui ça moi j'étais à
titre personnel j'étais un peu garçon
manqué je me disais quand on veut on
peut un peu naïve ans j'étais petit
donc j'ai fait j'ai eu un parcours assez
classe unique de classes préparatoires
puis de grandes écoles est vraiment être
dans cette dans ma tête quand on veut on
peut en fait j'ai été et finalement j'ai
été plus j'ai grandi que j'ai été exposé
à à nouveau c'est insidieux
c'est la façon dont qu'on s'intéresse à
vous quand vous rentrez dans une pièce
par exemple dans un dans un rendez-vous
investisseurs c'est la façon d'un de
prendre au sérieux c'est les questions
pour vous poser aussi sur votre
entreprise c'est toujours est-ce que
vous avez les épaules est-ce que c'est
toujours plus mise en doute sur votre
capacité à faire plutôt que
véritablement votre entreprise et vos
chiffres et évidemment et puis après
mois les grandes écoles sont des milieux
quand même assez aujourd'hui est connu
pour des comportements une macho donc
culturellement
c'était bien mieux quand même où il y
avait une culture une culture machiste
assez assez présente plus après moi je
me sens finance donc elle a également j
ai assez exposée
thomas dossier on voit que chloé incarne
une nouvelle génération qui peut être va
faire changer les choses mais on
découvre avec elle
effectivement des technologies sont
mises en place par des hommes et pour
des hommes et ne tiennent pas compte des
femmes alors là c'est carrément
structuration n'y a pas que les
technologies il ya des billets partout
et on
prendre les déconstruire elle est allée
regarder fois regarder ça en face déjà
il ya des billets nous par exemple quand
on prend des décisions politiques qui a
forcément des billets et comme on est
dans un monde qui est en train de
changer mais qui est aussi un monde
dominé par les hommes on prend des
décisions parfois là dessus et je vais
prendre un exemple à lyon en train de
mettre en place la municipalité pourra
mettre en place un budget sensible au
genre c'est à dire que sur chaque
dépense on va regarder c'est le profite
d'abord aux femmes ou aux hommes ou à
personne neutre
donc on va regarder un peu ati a qui
vont les subventions qu'on attribue
c'est juste à regarder ou vent où va
l'argent c'est important c'est le nom
qui le distribue à ce que l'on
privilégie d'abord un genre par rapport
à un autre
et puis après un peu se doter d'outils
les os les entreprises doivent se doter
d'outils un label il ya des labels il ya
un label afnor comme une norme qui peut
permettre de donner des outils de
management qui peuvent permettre de
regarder autrement le management la rh
etc pour faire avancer l'égalité femmes
hommes et puis pour arrêter de regarder
la société comme le regarder il ya 30 ou
40 ans c'est fou c'est des choses
auxquelles on pense même pas alexandra
burke et font tinter un effectivement et
je cite aussi un exemple que vous avez
donnée en préparant cette émission chloé
sont les airbags fait en fonction des
poids des hommes et donc ils ont mis en
danger des femmes peut-être que vous
aurez l'occasion de le raconter
alexandra burke fontan c'est sûr que sur
cette thématique est à deux sujets
d'abord la féminisation et la mixité des
métiers j'ai envie de dire par exemple
dans mon territoire des alpes-maritimes
on a essayé de mettre en place des
actions pour faire de la sensibilisation
justement à la mixité des métiers des
aux collégiens on a la technopole de
sophia antipolis qui est la première
technopole européenne avec énormément de
métiers scientifiques peu de femmes
également donc on les invite dans les
collèges pour pouvoir présenter leur
métier pour essayer d'attirer des jeunes
filles qui deviendront plus tarder des
scientifiques donc ça passe alors on
voit que se dirige vers l'est vers les
verts un bac scientifique
il est beaucoup plus de jeunes filles
qui ont des pattes mention très bien
scientifique et au moment de rentrer en
école c'est là où le bât blesse et on
voit que dans toutes ses écoles et elle
pourra
nous le dira certainement qu'il ya voilà
ça s'arrête parce que c'est toujours
pareil c'est toute l'image les
stéréotypes qu'on peut avoir qu il faut
absolument déconstruire et ça on parlait
de culture d'éducation il faut le faire
des jeunes à l faut déconstruire ça un
gamin quand il ya cinq six sept ans il
est pas encore genre et c'est la société
qui lui dit tu vas faire policier et tu
vas voir tu vas tu habillés en bleu est
l inverse pour ta soeur donc en fait il
ya 10 à ce problème at la féminisation
des métiers il faut rendre des métiers
beaucoup plus attractif et après il ya
les conséquences quand ces genres et et
l'application etc
mais c'est le cas aussi dans la
politique je veux dire aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises
pas assez pour le droit des femmes à mon
goût et donc c'est la féminisation elle
rajeunissement aussi de la classe
politique qui fait qu'on s'empare des
sujets donc
donc voilà il ya une incidence quand
donc c'est assez important en fait on
dit pas qu'il faut plus de femmes qu'on
est les meilleurs et c'est à aucun
rapport le sujet et les d'une
complémentarité est aujourd'hui faut
faire évoluer aussi les lois sur la
parité dans la politique pour parvenir à
cet objectif
on va y venir aux femmes en politique
avec notre troisième citoyenne dans un
instant chloé peut-être vous laisse
réagir je vouvoyais réagir à ce que
disaient nos élus notamment sur ce qu'on
se disait sur sur l'orientation en fait
c'est une question de représentation des
métiers et donc du coup d'éducation mais
aussi une question de en fait on va pas
dans une école par exemple
d'informatique ou les 90 % d'hommes et
10% de femmes parce que on sait que
c'est un endroit on va être victime du
sexisme les meilleurs silencieux oriente
canton avec 10% entre 90%
enfin c'est statistiquement ces
statistiques ont été les grandes chances
qu'on soit sujette à des blacks cesti
sexies des comportements déplacés etc
et du coup c'est pour ça aussi pour
boucler je pense à la suite c'est pour
ça que les quotas en fait peuvent avoir
de l'impact c'est que on va du coup se
retrouve avec des personnes qui vont
avoir de la représentation au moment de
l'orientation
ils vont voir qu'il ya 50 52 personnes
dans les dents dans leurs établissements
scolaires par exemple
et puis ensuite quand il cette personne
par les femmes par exemple ils seront
elles seront moins exposés avec cette
situation que très grande minorité et
donc du coup moins exposés à des
comportements sexistes et c'est donc
ondes mais je pense que ça la suite mais
servent les quotas justement les quotas
vous faites bien d'avoir des sujets en
une seconde oui non les quotas oui oui
il faut il faut absolument est passé
c'est qu'on ces personnes aiment les
quotas passe
le caractère obligatoire et dans la
politique ou par exemple dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises du cac 40 avec la loi copé
zimmermann s'il ya pas de quotas c'est
pas respecter donc malheureusement on le
vérifie tous les jours de classe où
c'est ce qu'a fait bouger la politique
exactement et il faut la faire encore
évoluer parce que notamment dans les
communautés de communes spc où il n'ya
pas de parité c'est un gros problème
alors justement gail berthevas ce vous
vous avez été mère au foyer pendant des
années mais aujourd'hui vous êtes maire
d'une commune rurale dans le morbihan
et vous aussi vous vous battez
quotidiennement pour plus de parité met
donc dans le monde politique comment
vous faites alors c'est pas simple c'est
un vrai combat clairement moi je suis
élu depuis 2008 en tant qu'adjointe j'ai
été élu maire en 2014 et en fait ces
demandes à la je me suis senti seul déjà
jeunes par rapport à la moyenne d'âge et
puis surtout très peu de femmes
donc on se dit que c'est pas possible
donc du coup voilà c'est aussi une
question de tempérament jeu j'aime bien
dire les choses donc quand je suis
entouré de mais voilà je le fais savoir
je réagis aussi un petit peu avec un peu
de répartie à toutes les petites blagues
un peu déplacé donc voila et puis bon
progressivement il faut s'imposer mais
c'est vrai que les femmes en fait c'est
pas naturel de s'imposer un homme en
politique dès lors qu'il est lui voilà
il va il va se sentir légitime une femme
elle va elle va vouloir démontrer sa
légitimité par sa force de travail
donc ça prend plus de temps donc il ya
besoin d'accompagner toutes ces femmes
les femmes qui sont nouvellement élus ou
les femmes qui seront candidats de
demain pour des élections
ça passe par la formation la formation
des élus ça passe aussi par des
évolutions législatives effectivement
moi je reste persuadé et pourtant je
suis contre les quotas vraiment sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on fait le constat que si
nous n'avions pas lui
ces lois pour favoriser la parité nous
serions loin de la situation à laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui qui pourtant
n'est pas encore satisfaisante puisqu'il
ya seulement à peine 20% de femmes mères
en france
donc vous êtes l'oisif je crois pour
l'écriture inclusive
oui alors j'essaye je suis par ailleurs
première vice présidente de mon
intercommunalités donc là où il ya très
peu de femmes
on a un exécutif paritaire voilà moi
dans mon écriture effectivement c'est
quand je parle des élus c'est les aigus
point e point s
mais ce n'est pas naturel et j'ai un
partenariat avec une association avec un
quotidien national
une newsletter on n'a pas réussi à
ancrer cette écriture inclusive et
newsletter qui parle des élus eh ben
c'est les élus us je trouve pas ça
devient quand on s'adresse à des élus je
trouve que c'est bien de pouvoir c'est
miniser parce que c'est important parce
que c'est aussi par ça qu'on va rendre
naturel le fait que des femmes puissent
être élus puissent être maire ou
président de l'intercommunale vous
sortez que vous déranger parfois que
vous agacé vous passez pour la féministe
de service ah oui et clairement alors je
ne le suis pas féministe 1 mais dans ce
combat voilà je suis obligé d'aller un
petit peu remuer les consciences donc je
suis intervenu là en congrès des maires
du morbihan il ya un an et demi sur
justement en préparation des échéances
municipales
le président de l'association des maires
m'avait demandé de faire une
intervention sur l'engagement des femmes
en politique
j'étais face à une assemblée de 300 élus
majoritairement homme un autre forcément
quand j'ai été annoncée sur le programme
quand je suis arrivé dans la salle
voilà c'est voilà la famille ni donner
des leçons pour aller chercher des
femmes pour mettre sur nos listes
mais c'est pas grave le tout c'est de
remuer un peu les consciences et une
fois que j'ai fait cette intervention
plusieurs plusieurs collègues maires
sont bons voire en disant oui tu as
raison on doit aussi changer nos façons
de faire c'est à dire que quand on
compose nos listes au lieu d'aller
trouver des femmes en leur disant ben
voila je viens de chercher pour être sur
ma liste parce que moi je suis comme une
pile mais l'habitant et formaliste elle
soit paritaire donc je ne cherchais non
ce n'est pas une façon de parler aux
femmes
donc nous on vient chercher les femmes
parce que on a décelé en la personne des
compétences parce que ça va être un
élément complémentaire d'une équipe est
pas tout simplement parce qu'on doit
mettre des femmes dans une équipe
alexandra burke et moi je viens vous
êtes aussi pardon on m'a fait réagir en
plateau pardonnez-moi le chrono tourne
très vite
vous êtes aussi une femme en politique
vous êtes une femme au sénat est ce que
c'est aussi une chambre qui a plus
d'hommes que de femmes
vous sentez que c'est plus difficile
pour vous que pour les hommes quand je
viens d'arriver il ya quand même une
plutôt une bienveillance pour les
nouveaux arrivés étant mieux en plus
c'est vrai qu'il ya une différence d'âge
et certains collègues ont l'âge de mes
parents donc il ya ce côté plutôt
sympathique et bienveillant donc je
pourrais pas dire que j'ai été mal
accueillis ou que j'ai ressenti du
sexisme
maintenant je peux engagée depuis dix
mille ans mais ça fait une dizaine
d'années que je suis engagé donc bien
sûr que je l' ai senti que voilà on est
jeune on est une femme et il a fallu
faire sa place ça m'a pas porté des faux
j'en suis là aujourd'hui j'en suis très
fier et honoré
mais voilà je veux pas dire que la ville
a commandé les évoluer les choses
gail berthevas se propose des choses
notamment l'écriture inclusive tout ça
alors moyen pour un clip c'est c'est moi
mon truc
moi en tant que qu'élu local bajeux
j'essaye de faire du concret donc de
créer des actions comme geste tout à
l'heure auprès des collégiens partouche
pense qu'il faut profiter justement de
nos mandats pour mettre en place des
actions vraiment qu'ils sont concrètes
concrètes pour faire évoluer les femmes
ce soit des actions de sensibilisation
auprès des jeunes ou là par exemple j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi
aujourd'hui sur l'endométriose crois que
ça n'a jamais été fait au sénat c'est
une
maladie qui touche une femme sur dix en
france donc voilà je profite aussi de
ses responsabilités que j'ai quelles que
soient les instances pour pouvoir
essayer de faire évoluer la condition de
la femme en général et on va y avoir du
boulot il ya encore du boulot thomas
devient bien sûr et comme disait votre
témoin la parité ça ne suffit pas il
faut aussi que les femmes conquis
candidate ou qui sont élus se sentent
légitimés à l'aise dans leur mandat il
faut trouver des outils pour qu'elle dit
arrive nous voilà dans l'organisation
que dans le cas qu'elle participe au
moment pour susciter des candidatures
était se sentent à l'aise
on a créé des espaces de non mixité ou
entre femmes entre ancien élu entre
candidates elles pouvaient se retrouver
partager l'expérience et continuer à
porter des choses de façon légitime
après bon évidemment on se retrouvait
tous ensemble mais il ya forcément des
temps où ça peut aussi aider se doter
d'outils comme ceci et puis je pense
aussi que la communication inclusive
permet aussi de faire évoluer les choses
faire évoluer les représentations
alors après on peut trouver des outils
forcément le point médian ou le point ça
forcément ça peut poser des problèmes on
peut trouver d'autres façons de le faire
mais en tout cas il faut féminisé au
maximum les noms des fonctions etc
il faut avancer sur surtout ça c'est
toutes ces représentations là qu'ils
feront à voir évoluer les choses et à
coincer n'a complètement paritaire avec
a évolué parce qu'avant votre émission
j'ai regardé les chiffres donc avant les
lois sur la parité c'était 5 à 6 % de
femmes au sénat on est autour de 30%
actuellement 24 8%
ça quand même ça évolue ça a évolué par
rapport à ces vite par rapport à la on
ne s'en est pas à 50 on est pas on n'est
pas représentatif de la population mais
en tout cas ça évolue on voit que c'est
les règles a été imposé dans les
intercoms aussi il faudrait il faudrait
mais c'est très compliqué parce que
interco ce sont les maires qui sont
souvent parfois le seul élu à l'interco
et comme on disait il ya très très peu
de mères femmes et donc ça pose un tas
de un tas de problèmes et oui il faut
évoluer à tuer et donc il ya encore du
boulot merci merci en tout cas à toutes
et à tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce
numéro inédit de dialogue citoyen merci
de vous être livrés d'ailleurs comme
vous l'avez fait et d'avoir partagé un
peu de vos vies un peu de votre intimité
de vos parcours merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et nous être fidèles comme
à chaque numéro on se retrouve
évidemment très vite sur public sénat
excellente soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]